Hollande Hollande idée soit il se fait
siffler il doit remanier ça va quoi
c'est le mec c'est pas non plus le
président de la République
maintenant je l'accueille Gaspard pour
elle est pas belle la vie
[Musique]
super super
parce que cette semaine c'était les
commémorations du 11 novembre donc il
faut passer une date très importante
dans l'histoire franco-allemande très
c'est quand même le seul moment de
l'histoire ou la France et l'Allemagne
ont réussi à synchroniser les congés
payés
d'ailleurs Hollande était assez mal à
l'aise devant la tombe du soldat inconnu
bon c'est normal quoi un moment il a
entendu toquer ouvre-moi c'est Jean-Marc
tu vois donc
sinon rien de rien de nouveau en ce
moment la France c'est la pas la pêche
enfin le droit
après le mariage pour tous qui nous a
tenu en haleine pendant un an voici venu
le temps du fruit exotique pour personne
[Musique]
comme chaque semaine la République est
en danger ouais c'est vraiment une
petite [__] la République
il suffit d'un jeu de mots douteux
griffonné par un journal qui a autant
d'impact que la revue motocross chez les
cul-de-jatte pour qu'elle nous fasse une
gastro-entérite verbale femme bon comme
beaucoup de monde j'ai été choqué c'est
quand même elle a une deux minutes des
skinnettes qui savent manier l'ironie je
suis pas
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai fait comme tout
le monde
j'ai voulu acheter minute bon j'y suis
allé molo pour pas éveiller les soupçons
du buraliste tu es bonjour vous avez le
magazine zoophilie et travaux
non non et la revue valeur pédophile
parce que non parce que c'est pas pour
moi c'est dans le cadre d'un exposé sur
fascisme au moment bien sûr allons aux
enfants de
un dîner nous étions tous indignés
[Applaudissements]
ça m'apprend plein de choses est-ce
qu'il était de Brignoles donc mais il
m'a dit attention je suis de Brignoles
nord de derrière la rocade parce que les
gens de brio le sud bah ils sont pas
comme nous alors là j'ai fait marche
arrière tout de suite Marion Maréchal
nous voilà et
là il me dit et là il me dit [__] elle
est bonne la petite alors je dis ah
ouais c'est vrai mais
et là il me dit ben désolé de vous
décevoir mais minutes j'en ai plus
d'habitude j'en vends deux par mois et
là depuis le début de la journée ça fait
la quinzième fois qu'on le demande moi
je me suis dit les socialistes sont
quand même forts [__] de publicitaire
voici dans cette semaine encore et
toujours on parle de
Hollande Hollande il déçoit il se fait
siffler il doit remanier ça va quoi
c'est le mec c'est pas non plus le
président de la République
oh non bravo bravo
Gaspard
et énorme ce qui est quand même
intéressant avec les sondages sur
Hollande c'est qu'on va bientôt pouvoir
connaître l'identité des gens qui le
soutiennent
il y a 2 % de personnes très satisfaites
donc sur 1000 personnes ça fait 20
personnes qui peuvent appeler le numéro
vert suivant
bon après les Français sont un peu con
je pense qu'on l'a assez ils sont déçus
ils sont en colère au lieu de se mettre
un bonnet rouge mettez-vous un bonnet
d'âne pour croire encore un homme
providentiel
[Applaudissements]
qui peut encore rentrer dans le costume
de De Gaulle je rappelle qu'il faisait 2
mètres enfin
sur le général l'habit de Président
c'est un costard mais sur Sarko Hollande
ça fait burqa
[Applaudissements]
mais je pense parce qu'il a besoin
d'amour cet homme-là
il a pas encore trouvé sa voie ici
cherche je pense que Hollande c'est le
plus vieil emploi jeune de France
quand on pense qu'il est plus
impopulaire que Sarko alors que dans son
entourage il y a même pas Nadine Morano
non parce que Sarko avait une entourage
beaucoup plus pittoral et quoi tu vois
enfin voilà présentatrice télé un
bouquin sur verdict les nanas de
Hollande elles vont faire quoi après
faire Marisol Touraine elle va rebondir
dans quoi le tirage des tarots et j'ai
rien fait au loup tu vois
alors
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on y a ailleurs
j'aimerais vraiment
qui mais qui dégommé il y a Copé
on peut pas enfin on est humain il a les
mêmes sondages que Hollande sans être au
pouvoir il a besoin de personne
[Applaudissements]
international Philippines alors tout le
monde a entendu ce drame tu me connais
j'ai fait un geste pour les Philippines
j'ai une femme de ménage qui vient de
là-bas alors je lui ai dit oui
aujourd'hui vous touchez pas la
baignoire la douche le séchoir
[Applaudissements]
car après
tu me connais j'ai pas pu m'empêcher
pour lui faire peur j'ai fait un courant
d'air
enfin j'ai appelé les pompiers pour la
descente du lustre
musique Pleyel le fabricant de piano a
fermé son usine en Seine-Saint-Denis pas
grand corps malade a vu ça il a dit bah
c'est normal aujourd'hui plus personne
tape à la machine
sexe pour revenir à Hollande Nabilla
conseil à Hollande de faire une sextape
pour annoncer sa popularité avec des
déclarations pareil on a hâte que
Nabilla soit un populaire
ah oui peut-être terminé sur une bonne
nouvelle parce que Aubry est pressenti à
Matignon ça serait malin si elle se
plante et pourra toujours dire oui mais
moi je bosse 35 heures
alors
pas belle la vie et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu